>>> JOINING US NOW, BILL BARR.
HIS NEW BOOK IS ONE DAMN THING
AFTER ANOTHER.
GREAT TITLE.
I KNOW IT IS NOT YOUR SAYING.
YOU WRITE IN ONE OF YOUR BOOKS,
THERE IS THE ONE OF THE MOST
MEMORABLE SCENES.
YOU CALL THE PRESIDENT THROWING
A FIT, YOU CALL IT A TANTRUM.
THINGS IN THE WAKE OF GEORGE
FLOYD'S MURDER.
YOU WROTE, THE PRESIDENT LOST
HIS COMPOSURE.
HE SWEPT HIS INDELVE CIRCLE
AROUND THE SEMICIRCLE POINTING
AT ALL OF US.
YOU'RE ALL LOSERS, HE YELLED.
REDDENING.
HE FELT WE WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE VIOLENCE AROUND THE COUNTRY.
YOU'RE LOSERS.
TINY ARCS OF SPIT.
YOU'RE ALL LOSERS.
I WAS TAKEN A BACK.
I WANTED TO READ IT FOR YOU.
THIS IS NOT THE ONLY TIME IN THE
BOOK YOU WRITE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS TEMPERAMENT
WHICH YOU SUGGEST IS
DISQUALIFYING DEFINITELY THOSE
OUTBURSTS EVER CAUSE TO YOU
QUESTION HIS FITNESS FOR OFFICE
OR HIS STABILITY?
>> NO.
I DIDN'T CONSIDER HIM
DISQUALIFYING.
I SUPPORTED HIS POLICIES.
I WAS VERY CONSCIOUS OF HIS
PERSONAL FAILINGS, ESPECIALLY
HIS PETTINESS AND HIS TEMPER
WHEN HE'S NOT GETTING HIS WAY,
HIS DISPOSITION TO LISTEN.
HE ONLY WANTS TO HEAR WHAT HE
WANTS TO HEAR.
UP UNTIL THE ELECTION, I FELT IF
HE HAD STRONG CABINET
SECRETARIES WHO WERE WILLING TO
DO BATTLE, YOU COULD KEEP THINGS
ON TRACK AND I PERSONALLY FELT
THAT WE DID A GET JOB OF THAT.
AFTER THE ELECTION, THERE WAS
NO, HE WENT OFF THE RAILS.
HE WAS NOT LISTENING TO HIS
NORMAL ADVISERS.
HE WAS LISTENING TO THOSE THAT
SAID IT WAS STOLEN.
>> YOU DEFINITELY WRITE THAT
SOMETHING CHANGED AFTER THE
ELECTION.
YOU WRITE THAT YOU WERE
DISGUSTED BY THINGS HE SAID OR
DID.
YOU SAID HE TOOK A DANGEROUS
TURN AFTER THE ELECTION BUT
SIGNIFICANTLY DETAXED FROM
REALITY.
IT IS DIMINISHES HIM IN THE
OFFICE.
IN THE SPRING OF 2020, YOU SAID
HE WAS ACTING LIKE A HYPERACTIVE
MANIAC.
>> HE'S NOT MY IDEA OF A
PRESIDENT AND I FELT HE WOULD
LOSE THE ELECTION BECAUSE HE WAS
NOT CONTROLLING HIMSELF.
HE WAS ALLOWING HIS PETTINESS TO
COME THROUGH AND I FEEL IT IS
ONE OF HIS GREAT FAILINGS.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE AGREE
WITH HIS POLICIES.
THEY LIKE HIS STRENGTH AND
DIRECTNESS.
TO THE EXTENT THEY SUPPORT HIM,
IT IS DESPITE THIS OBNOXIOUS
BEHAVIOR.
IT IS NOT BECAUSE OF IT.
>> YOUR BOOK WE UNDERSTAND THE
CONCLUSION THAT THE PARTY AND
THE COUNTRY WOULD BE BETTER
SUITED IF A DIFFERENT CANDIDATE
LED THE WAY GOING FORWARD.
YOU SAY THERE'S AN IMPRESSIVE
ARRAY OF OTHERS.
IF TRUMP RUNS, WOULD YOU GET
INVOLVED IN THE PRIMARY FIGHT TO
DEFEAT HIM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> TO SUPPORT ONE OF THE OTHER
CANDIDATES?
>> YES.
I THINK THE COMING PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION WOULD BE A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
FROM MY STANDPOINT, THE
PROGRESSIVE LEFT HAS, IS SORT OF
SHOWING SORT OF A TOTALITARIAN
TEMPERAMENT AND I THINK THE
REPUBLICANS CAN WIN A DECISIVE
MAJORITY.
BUT I DON'T THINK WE CAN DO IT
WITH TRUMP.
HE'S JUST TOO DIVISIVE A
CANDIDATE.
>> WHO ARE SOME OF THE
REPUBLICANS YOU'RE LOOKING AT?
>> WELL, THERE ARE A WHOLE SLEW
OF THEM AND I'LL LET THEM RUN
AROUND THE TRACK FOR A WHALE.
BUT I WOULD DEFINITELY SUPPORT
ANY OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
>> WOULD YOU SUPPORT LIZ CHENEY
OVER DONALD TRUMP?
>> I DON'T THINK SHE COULD GET
THE NOMINATION.
>> AS MUCH AS YOU CRITICIZE
TRUMP NOW IN THE BOOK, YOU'RE
TELLING, AND YOU SAY YOU'RE
DISGUSTED BY THE THINGS HE DID.
THE TONE OF YOUR DEPARTURE
LETTER WAS QUITE DIFFERENT.
YOU WROTE, I AM GREATLY HONORED
THAT YOU CALL ON ME TO SERVE
YOUR ADMINISTRATION AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I'M PROUD TO HAVE PLAYED A ROLE
IN THE MANY SUCCESSES AND
ACHIEVEMENTS YOU HAVE DELIVERED
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YOUR RECORD IS ALL THE MORE
HISTORIC BECAUSE YOU
ACCOMPLISHED IT IN THE FACE OF
RELENTLESS, IMPLACABLE
RESISTANCE.
WHY AREN'T YOU SAYING THEN WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING NOW?
THIS IS DECEMBER 2020.
IT MIGHT HAVE HAD AN EFFECT ON
WHAT HAPPENED JANUARY 6th.
>> RIGHT.
WELL.
>> AT THE TIME, THE STATES HAD
ALREADY CERTIFIED THEIR VOTES.
I FELT THE DIE WAS CAST.
HE WAS ALREADY LEAVING OFFICE.
WHAT I KEPT TELLING HIM IS,
PARADE YOUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS OUT
THERE.
BELIEVE SOME DIGNITY.
PUT YOUR RECORD BEFORE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU THOUGHT AT
THE TIME.
>> RIGHT.
AND THAT'S WHY I WROTE A LETTER
THAT LAID OUT HIS ACHIEVEMENTS.
I THINK THOSE ARE ACHIEVEMENTS.
I'M PROUD OF THOSE ACHIEVEMENTS
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION.
AND I DIDN'T WANT THEM TO BE
LOST SIGHT OF.
AND YES, I AM CRITICAL OF HIM,
DEFINITELY, IN THE BOOK.
I ALSO GIVE HIM A LOT OF CREDIT.
>> DO YOU, LOOKING BACK ON IT,
KNOWING THAT HE DIDN'T TAKE YOUR
ADVICE.
HE DIDN'T RUN AROUND THE COUNTRY
TALKING ABOUT OPERATION WARM
SPEED.
TALKING ABOUT THE ABRAHAM
ACCORDS, THE MANY THINGS YOU
TALK ABOUT IN THIS BOOK THAT
YOU'RE PROUD OF BORDER SECURITY,
ET CETERA.
DO YOU REGRET NOT SAYING
SOMETHING IN DECEMBER MORE
VOCIFEROUSLY THAN DID YOU, WHICH
MIGHT HAVE BEEN AN EFFECT ON
DAMPENING WHAT HAPPENED?
STOPPING WHAT HAPPENED JANUARY
6th?
>> WELL, FIRST, I TWICE CAME OUT
PUBLICLY.
NOT ONLY ON DECEMBER 1st TO THE
AP REPORTER, BUT ALSO, I GAVE A
PRESS CONFERENCE BEFORE I LEFT
WHERE I REITERATED THAT.
THAT THERE WAS NOT EVIDENCE OF
FRAUD THAT WOULD AFFECT THE
ELECTION AND I REFUSED TO
APPOINT AN INDEPENDENT COUNSEL
TO LOOK INTO THE ELECTION AND SO
FORTH.
I THOUGHT HE WAS HISTORY AND I
WAS RIGHT.
HE WAS HISTORY AS OF DECEMBER
14th WHEN THE STATES CERTIFIED
THE VOTE.
I BELIEVED HE WAS LEAVING OFFICE
AND THAT WAS THAT.
I COULDN'T SEE AHEAD TO THE
DISRUPTION ON JANUARY 6th.
SO I DIDN'T SEE ANY POINT IN
GETTING UP A